what are you so happy about twilight
breaking dawn part 2 is coming out wait
a minute when did you drink the kool-aid
on that I didn't I'm just glad it's
finally over now this crummy eyesore can
go away no more Team Edward or Team
Jacob no more sobbing giddy tweens
clogging up the fantasy aisle at the
bookstore and that over muscle douche is
gonna have to buy a shirt you know maybe
you two should lay off the twihards I
know that you are not about to defend
sparkling vampires know the listen we've
all people should be promoting
intellectual tolerance I mean how is us
picking on gushing teenagers any
different from you being picked on
because you're a Dungeons and Dragons
gamer or you for wearing a Darth Maul
t-shirt to your first college party or
me for giving a toast in Klingon at my
sister's wedding who are we to judge
aren't we all just different shades in
the great geek rainbow can't we be happy
for them or at least leave them in peace
sparkling vampires oh sorry guys I don't
know what came over me